oh my god hi I'm Hannah I'm the worlds
of case mom and I want to talk about
Kylie Jenner for a second now I don't
actually know that much about her but I
do remember when she had her daughter
stormy she caught a lot of flack online
for having long nails now I have a
newborn so I actually want to see what
all the fuss is about and see if it was
worth mom shaming her for it so for an
entire week I'm going to attempt to
parent wearing Kylie Jenner's signature
coffin nails and see how I do wish me
luck we are here at the nail place I
brought my two sidekicks because this
nail place is kind of special
it's called mommy's retreat they have a
playroom where who will watch her kids
when Kylie hosted the photo I just
remember feeling so sorry for her
because I was a young mom too I remember
how vulnerable I felt and how
embarrassed and insecure in my parenting
skills but honestly I was very curious
to see how she actually pulled that off
with those nails and so I decided to try
it we opted for what's called gel X
which is basically like a glue on nail
she uses acrylics but I was not in this
for the long haul
it's really hard to write what do you
guys think of my nail
why do you like him I actually really
love them there it's gonna be really
hard to function but they feel so
glamorous and fancy I'm actually kind of
obsessed with okay here's the deal
I cannot unbuckle why of car seat
they're too long
quick hit sense and literally can't push
oh my god okay let's see no nope
oh maybe yeah hi what do you think oh my
gosh look at those things the first
thing I discovered right away is that
vlogging with these nails is very hard
the buttons on my camera are very tiny
we usually edit out most of my stumbles
but there was too much to edit out first
challenge happened right away as soon as
I got home I had to change Henry sniper
and this was something I was very afraid
to do after I got the nails on like
feeling them and seeing how long they
were I did not know if I could do it oh
my god I am NOT going to last a week in
these nails changing the diaper took
about three times as long as it usually
does but I was successful
I can't do it
I know I know I know you're sick of this
you're sick of this I'm so sorry
oh come here come to your mother
next was buckling Henry into his car
seat ready we're gonna try this babies
are very tiny and wiggly and then the
car seat is small it's a confined space
with these big-ass nail oh and it's like
it was essentially like defusing a bomb
like very calculated you're so patient
Henry y-yeah okay those really hard
that was really hard these are like one
inch too long very quickly
zippers and snaps became the bane of my
existence because with nails that long I
had to use the pads of my fingers for
everything but when there's a very tiny
zipper my pads don't reach it like
physically I could not reach a lot of
things with my fingers because the nails
were so long and so in the way it's like
having five extra appendages that I have
no real control over I feel like watch
where each one is snaps
[Music]
baby hoods are either all snaps or all
zippers and I grabbed the wrong outfit a
[Music]
diaper cream all in nails next it was
bath time I was really dreading the bath
because it really felt like I was
bathing a child with scissors in each
hand it was like like bare skin is very
delicate on babies and so at least when
Henry is dressed and I'm holding him and
stuff there's a barrier between my nails
and his skin but bath time was gonna be
complete like nail to skin contact
parenting aside these nails had an
impact on my everyday life too a lot of
easy tasks became very difficult in the
middle of the week I was starting to get
the hang of things but a couple things
came up throughout that were still a
little bit tricky oh gosh oh gosh okay
okay wait I can't hit my PowerUp it's so
hard my kids love playing video games
together as a family and so they asked
me to play Mario Kart with them and of
course that is the one game that uses
like half a switch controller and so
it's the tiniest tiniest buttons for
these big nails
and this is the power of last year's
a lot of people have been curious to
know if Wyatt has gotten less dramatic
since Henry's arrival and the short and
long answer is no I'm going to attempt
to wear Henry in the baby carrier
because that's literally how I get
everything done during the day he does
not like being put down
it's how I eat I'm so hungry it's almost
2 o'clock and I haven't eaten and I'm
gonna try to get him in the carrier but
I don't know if it's gonna work too hard
for me to do with these nails we
actually did it that back buckle that
was really tricky I feel very
accomplished I'm gonna assume that Kylie
does not baby wear if she does maybe not
one with buckles once I mastered the
baby carrier things got a lot easier and
I got a lot more productive because I
had two free hands so what I wanted to
tackle next was cooking dinner
[Music]
oh man
I cannot stand these rocks can
that is exactly why I hate those I cook
a lot and it's one of the reasons why I
have really short nails I'm just gonna
sautee the spinach with these bell
peppers it's difficult for me to cook
when my nails are anything other than
super short I felt very awkward come
take a look oh yeah look at that bubble
meatball baked like biscuits and
meatballs and cheese by the end of the
week life with nails was getting
significantly easier okay I'm getting
the hang yeah baby yeah I even came up
with a couple genius hacks in my opinion
for functioning with these bad boys oh
that was not asked traumatic as I
thought it would be I should have been
using these for diaper changes all along
because they like dull everything sharp
I missed the mark and not using these
for some initial diaper changes that
were very precarious and took a lot
longer than they needed to before the
week was over there was one last thing
that I wanted to do and that was post a
photo like Kylie's to see if I would get
the same response that she did Kylie
Jenner I think you mean Hannah William I
never in my life thought that our names
would be in the same sentence people are
so nice and I got a lot of compliments
on the nails I got a lot of people you
know coming to my defense if anybody
even questioned them and it proved to me
either we've come a long way as moms in
terms of mom shaming and being more
positive on the Internet or I am
so incredibly lucky to have the
community of people around me
that I do so after a week of these nails
did I have a hard time functioning yes
am I going to immediately remove them
also yes but am I ever going to judge
anyone else for having them absolutely
not
keep in mind I'm a person who has never
had long nails in my life and if I can
function for a week with these think of
how someone who's used to having long
nails is going to function it's doable
it's fine and it works and it's
something very cosmetic that makes a mom
feel more human I felt the same way when
I dyed my hair blue I got a lot of
comments I got a lot of looks I got a
lot of judgment but it was something
that made me feel more human and it made
me feel like I was doing something for
myself okay I'm gonna go get these taken
off that's I got for today I'm Hannah
and how do you think I did with those
nails did I do okay have you ever had
coffin nails let me know on Instagram
know who please excuse me he's ready to
take a look yes till next time
[Music]
yes now I look cool